no one welcome to this video yeah I'm
very happy to announce that the
long-awaited new course to keep it
simple 1.d4 is actually released it's on
now form two hours or something it's on
chasuble
and you can buy it and it's currently on
sale of course as a for the start and it
will be formed quite a long time they
start 23 days til end of June because
there will be a sale for them or thing
let me I had this one so this is a
really really great complete course on
1.d4 it is a full repertoire and in fact
there will be a video more about about
more than the content a little bit later
what I'm going to do with this video is
just to quickly announce that it is out
in the open it can be purchased on
chasuble and I will do something later
today and that will be at 9 p.m. Central
European Time there will be a
simultaneous display on Leach s where I
will be playing white and I will test
out the repertoire against you guys so
make sure to join only chess tonight umm
and that would also be of course live
streamed here on YouTube so make sure to
join in and keep watching the channel
for more info and also link to a free
video a little bit later thanks for
watching